[Musique]
bienvenue dans audition publique et
bienvenue Christophe Béchu nous sommes
ensemble pour une heure comme tous les
lundis sur LCP et Public Sénat merci à
vous d'avoir accepté notre invitation
nous ne sommes pas à un moment banal de
ce début de quinquennat vous êtes
Ministre chargé d'un sujet majeur dans
l'équipe d'Elizabeth borne la transition
écologique vous êtes rare dans les
médias certains vous en projets d'être
aux abonnés absents ces derniers mois
vous êtes au courant que votre collègue
de la santé vous a coopté dans le club
des Invisibles bon c'est pas très
flatteur mais autant en sourire mais
pourquoi cette discrétion alors que
franchement il n'y a pas de temps à
perdre saurez-vous aller vite maintenant
maintenant que le temps peut être vous
est compté comme à celui d'ailleurs du
gouvernement d'Elizabeth borne nous
évoquerons ensemble vos dossiers sainte
Soline sébacine c'est violence la
sécheresse qui s'annonce cet été votre
plan eau sera-t-il suffisant n'arrive
pas t-il n'arrive-t-il pas pardon trop
tard et puis au menu évidemment la
puissante contestation de la réforme des
retraites Brigitte boucher tam-trainuit
reviendront sur toute cette question
vous étiez il y a encore quelques mois
merde danger vous faites partie de
l'équipe du parti horizon d'Édouard
Philippe Yves réars vous interrogera sur
les perspectives de la majorité Vincent
roux pour l'actu vous avez accepté de
débattre et on vous en remercie avec
Mélanie Vogel sénatrice Europe Écologie
Les Verts déjà quelques questions on va
dire d'atmosphère politique puisque
cette semaine c'est une semaine de
consultation en particulier celle
mercredi à Matignon Elisabeth borne va
recevoir l'interfe syndicale à quoi ça
sert à quoi ça sert quand on a une inter
syndicale qui est arboutée sur le refus
du passage de l'âge légal à 64 ans et
que vous-même vous le gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron Elizabeth bandit non
vous refusez de bouger à quoi ça sert
pour soirée Elisabeth Marty sur
cet accueil de ce menu particulièrement
copieux avec avec beaucoup de sujets se
parler en démocratie c'est jamais
inutile maintenir ou retrouver un
contact c'est une étape obligatoire
parce qu'il y aura quelque soit l'issue
un après retraite et se mettre dans la
tête quand quelque sorte il faudrait ne
plus parler ne plus discuter ne plus
échanger ce serait le contraire de ce
que doit être toute démarche politique
vous allez vous allez évidemment j'ai
une forme pardon est-ce que ça n'est pas
pour amuser la galerie en attendant la
décision le 14 avril du Conseil
constitutionnel les syndicats vont
peut-être claquer la porte au bout d'une
demi heure mais ça sert à quoi cette
mise en scène c'est pour justement pour
mettre en scène une action politique qui
n'existe pas je crois pas du tout ça et
je vous demande d'imaginer quelques
instants la scène si à l'inverse il y
avait le refus de toute discussion de
toute réunion avec l'Inter syndicale le
fait d'expliquer que la porte était
fermée jusqu'au 14 avril et en quelque
sorte le pays sous cloche en attendant
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
quel que soit cette décision est-ce que
le débat précisément sur les retraites
n'a pas révélé d'autres angles morts
d'autres aspérités d'autres angoisses
d'autres attentes à la fois des salariés
et plus largement de la société faire en
sorte dans ce moment compliqué tendu de
montrer que il y a au contraire une
volonté de part et d'autre de la garder
de regarder de regarder au-delà de cet
épisode en réalité une réforme des
retraites il y en a eu dans tous les
pays européens et dans tous les pays
européens aujourd'hui on travaille plus
longtemps qu'en France et dans la
plupart de ces pays il y a une forme
d'indexation
au-delà de ce sujet au-delà de cette
nécessité parce qu'on a choisi dans ce
pays un système qui est un système par
répartition qui fait que les actifs
payent pour les retraités mais qu'on
soit capable de bien mesurer que ça
n'est pas le seul sujet sur la table
avec les partenaires sociaux je trouve
ça au contraire plutôt rapide c'est
intéressant parce que vous vous
présentez des arguments que le
gouvernement effectivement et graines
depuis des mois qu'est-ce que vous avez
raté qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché
on pourra refaire un petit examen de
conscience déjà maintenant on pourra
certainement un jour refaire le film de
l'événement le fait de se demander si
cette réforme dans un contexte qui est
celui de tension sur le pouvoir d'achat
sur l'inflation avec la guerre en
Ukraine les arguments mais est-ce que
c'est également Elizabeth Martichoux du
moment
le sujet aujourd'hui il est très
clairement le fait de reprendre langue
de regarder
le 14 avril et au-delà parce que les
difficultés dans d'autres domaines les
pressions géopolitiques l'urgence
climatique elles se sont pas arrêtées
elles se sont pas suspendues et elles
continuent d'exister c'est un sujet en
tout cas sur lequel évidemment vous
allez revenir largement juste une
question parce que la feuille de route
d'Elizabeth borne pour cette période
c'est de tenter d'élargir d'élargir son
équipe éventuellement l'équipe du
gouvernement
vous qui observez en particulier les
rangs de la droite
avec qui vous pourriez gouverner
donnez-nous un nom qui vous semblerait
finalement
un nombre qui serait
utile pour vous pour gouver pour le
gouvernement si votre question elle
porte sur des talons individuels il y en
a évidemment si votre question elle
porte sur le souhait d'un élargissement
qui soit plus politique je crois
davantage au fait d'agréger des forces
plutôt que d'aller seulement chercher
des individualités et pour être très
clair pas quand vous dites quand vous
dites que les choses semblent complexes
il y a plus de la moitié du groupe LR
qui n'a pas voté la motion de censure
malgré le caractère impopulaire de la
réforme des retraites ils ont pris leur
responsabilité par rapport à ce qu'ils
avaient défendu au monde l'élection
présidentielle ou par le passé avec une
forme de constance dans ce qui avait eu
pu être les positions de l'UMP puis des
républicains donc des gens qui se
soucient du pays et pas seulement
de la durée de vie du gouvernement ou de
leur propre carrière il y en a à
l'extérieur de la majorité et il faut
juste s'efforcer de continuer à discuter
sur le fond précisément et pas d'abord
sur les questions de personnes on y
reviendra Brigitte boucher se sont
assise en face de vous bonsoir à toutes
les deux brigitte c'est à vous oui
marine Tondelier a traité Gérald
Darmanin de pyromane attisant la
violence présentant l'écologie comme de
l’écho terrorisme est-ce que finalement
le ministre de l'Intérieur ne dramatise
pas à dessin la situation pour vous
faire apparaître comme le parti de
l'ordre
si vous faites référence à ce qui s'est
passé à Sainte Soline je veux dire qu'il
y a un moment où il faut appeler les
choses par leur nom
jeter des boules de pétanque sur des
gendarmes
se munir de bonbonne de gaz tirer des
mortiers d'artifice venir avec des armes
qui sont des armes qui peuvent tuer ça
n'est pas être écologiste c'est utiliser
le prétexte de l'écologie pour se livrer
un déferlement de violence et donc si on
considère
quand maman les casseurs
on porte du tort à l'écologie on se
trompe lourdement ce qui porte du tort à
l’écologie c'est au contraire de ne pas
dénoncer avec force la nuance entre être
contre un projet quel qu'il soit avec
des avec des arguments et utiliser la
violence la légitimer ou en tout cas ne
pas la dénoncer quand on est en face de
scène comme celle qu'on entretient pas
justement une confusion entre les
manifestants écologistes contre ce
projet et les casseurs activistes
c'est pas le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
a armé des centaines de gens qui ont
fait pas de différence entre entre des
militants
écologistes qui qui n'étaient pas venu
casser qui était juste contre ce projet
et qui était pour le droit à manifester
donc tout dans éco terrorisme c'est le
terme qui l'emploie je pense qu'il y a
un raccourci dans la manière dont on dit
les choses encore une fois vous êtes le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous êtes au
soir d'une journée où vous avez des
dizaines de gendarmes qui ont été
blessés alors qu'ils ont seulement été
missionnés pour faire leur job et pour
être présent sur le terrain je comprends
que l'émotion au vu à la fois des images
et des retours que vous avez de vos
propres rangs elle vous conduisent à
dénoncer non seulement ce qu'ils l'ont
tiré dessus mais ce qui en plus le soir
explique que les violences elles
seraient du côté des forces de l'ordre
et pas des manifestants il y a quand
même une forme d'inversion de l'histoire
qui consiste à présenter les vérité de
manière alternative je n'englobe
évidemment pas tous les manifestants de
Sainte-Soline ou tous les écologistes je
n'ai jamais
ce que je dis juste c'est qu'à un moment
on attend au contraire de cela qu'il
soit les premiers à dire c'est pas ça
l'écologie et on peut pas sous couvrir
d'écologie sans prendre à la vie des
autres les écologistes responsables
d'ailleurs parfois élu comme une
tandelier qui disent il y avait trop
finalement il y avait trop de gendarmes
et trop de policiers à Sainte Soline et
c'est ça qui est attisé les violences
ils sont pas responsables c'est un
manque de responsabilité c'est une
réécriture de l'histoire au mois de
octobre
une manifestation a débouché sur plus de
60 gendarmes blessés dont un grièvement
à l'issue de sa contenue des
renseignements de l'ambiance qui montait
des appels et des mots d'ordre à se
réunir à nouveau à Sainte Soline au mois
de mars la préfète a interdit ces
manifestations
qu'il y ait des gendarmes et des
policiers pour faire face à ce que les
renseignements avaient indiqué
c'est-à-dire la présence potentielle de
Black Blocs de casseurs venant
d'ailleurs pas seulement de France pour
s'en prendre de manière délibérée aux
forces de l'ordre imposait d'avoir un
dispositif qui sont à la hauteur des
renseignements qui étaient pris ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est que des partis
politiques à une non seulement ont
défendre je pensais évidemment à la
France insoumise en l'espèce ou Europe
Écologie Les Verts a y défendre le
principe de participer à une
manifestation interdite alors qu'il y a
un risque et d'ordre public et
qu'ensuite le soir de ces événements ils
ont le droit et qu'ensuite au soir de
ces événements on aille en quelque sorte
un criminer les forces de l'ordre ça
c'est quelque chose qui me dépasse et je
pense sincèrement envoyer que ça dessert
la cause de l'écologie tout comme
certains dans ces mêmes partis
politiques qui font une espèce de
raccourci qui consiste à dire si on
n'est pas de gauche on peut pas être
écologiste
mais Gérald Darmanin par exemple il
accuse il parle d'extrême gauche quand
il parle de la nude il parle de
terrorisme intellectuel quand après vous
allez dire c'est la violence verbale
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale qui entraîne la violence de
rue est-ce que finalement il fait pas
exactement la même chose
en utilisant ces termes
moi comprendre l'origine du fait de
savoir qui a commencé comment les choses
se passent très sincèrement pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens que ce
soit quand ils regardent ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle ou quand il regarde ce
qui se passe à la fin de certaines
manifestations ou ce qui s'est passé
presque dès le début de la manifestation
de sainte Soline je pense pas qu'ils
soient en train de se demander qui a
commencé avec ce type de raisonnement il
voit une chose c'est que on peut pas en
République sans prendre à l'intégrité
physique des forces de l'ordre sans
prendre à l'intégrité physique des
forces de l'orgue on va pas aller
chercher le prétexte la justification ou
la légitimation
de gauche pour trouver une issue
politique à la crise là on a quand même
l'impression que Gérald Darmanin attise
le fumé de l'huile sur le feu quand même
écoutez il y a un dessin politique
commandé de
un but encore une fois on l'espèce quand
vous avez plus de 1000 policiers et
gendarmes qui ont été blessés
au cours de ces dernières semaines je
pense que de parler
d'instrumentalisation
c'est déplacé je crois pas du tout ça
quand il exprime les choses avec une
émotion qu'il vit aux côtés de ces
gendarmes et ses policiers une question
subsidiaire marine Tondelier a annoncé
porter plainte pour diffamation contre
vous pour accusation mensongère et
outrancière pour un tweet que je cite un
jeté de la soupe sur des œuvres défendre
ceux qui jettent des boules de pétanque
sur des gendarmes c'est lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique est-ce qu'il y a
eu des suites
écoutez j'ai au courant du dépôt d'une
plainte contre vous de passer un tweet
10 ans ça je n'ai eu absolument aucun
élément et je maintiens évidemment des
propos qui consistent effectivement à
dire que je vois pas bien mais c'est la
discussion qu'on est en train d'avoir
vous considérez pas que ces mensonges
d'expliquer que jeter des boules de
pétanque sur des gendarmes ça n'est pas
lutter contre les règlements climatiques
je pense que c'est très exact et je
pense que c'est ce que tout le monde
pense d'accord vous voyez les
écologistes en fait pas du tout c'était
on est à nouveau dans le contexte de
sainte Soline par rapport à la défense
je sais même plus le contexte c'est un
tweet qui date d'il y a plusieurs mois
pour la soupe
alors on va on va reprendre sur le fond
on a appris 40 qu'il y a 42 sites sous
surveillance c'est une carte qui a été
dévoilée par le Journal du Dimanche un
des sites à haut risque il y a des
contestations de projets pour des
raisons environnementales et parmi ces
sites il y a la liaison entre Toulouse
et Castres à une autoroute de 54 km
alors on la voit à l'écran d'ailleurs la
petite portion ensuite pour faire gagner
alors selon les versions entre 15 et 30
minutes de temps pour 8000 voitures
c'est un projet en réflexion depuis 30
ans est-ce qu'elle n'est pas devenue
aujourd'hui un peu anachronique
c'est un vrai sujet le fait de savoir
contenu en particulier la longueur de
nos procédures de DUP des recours
multiples qui peuvent arriver à quel
moment la légalité d'un projet si elle a
été constatée même de manière antérieure
elle reste valable mais on a des règles
et des lois et qu'est-ce qui fait
aujourd'hui que on pourrait
autoriser un groupe une association a
considéré que devient illégal quelque
chose qui a été validé par la justice et
des recours juridiques actuellement je
sais bien mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous répondre ce soir sur ce
bout d'autoroute dans le fond est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est légitime bien de
se reposer la question de aujourd'hui on
estime que et bien faut pas encourager
autant le transport automobile etc que
ça peut poser des problèmes en termes de
biodiversité est-ce que vous le ministre
bien de l'environnement vous trouvez que
la question doit se reposer
précisément
il faut regarder par territoire si vous
me demandez mon avis de manière générale
c'est simple la ligne du gouvernement
elle est simple nous allons diminuer les
crédits pour les routes dans le cadre
des contrats de plan et ta région on va
massifier de manière considérable les
investissements dans le ferroviaire ont
défend les transports en commun on
accompagne la décarbonations mais c'est
pas le moment il faut pas donner genre
de projet quand il y a beaucoup de
contestations que je suis simplement en
train de vous dire c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas résumer la totalité de la
France de ces départements de ces villes
à une sorte de ligne qui serait la même
de Dunkerque à Toulon on ne regarde pas
parfois les spécificités locales la
réalité de ce qui a pu être attendu et
ce serait vraiment un exercice de Total
déconnexion avec la France de penser que
un ministre depuis son bureau avec un
stabilo peut dire tel projet il y a le
mot routier dedans je le fais pas tel
projet il y a le mot ferroviaire dedans
je le fais alors que ça serait une
manifestation volonté politique pour
lutter pour l'environnement ce serait
une manifestation était poétique la
manifestation de volonté politique c'est
de diminuer les crédits pour les routes
en revanche
ça peut est-ce que ça peut redevenir des
nouveaux sens solides alors
je vais pas vous répondre 42 fois sur
chacun des 42 projets en ayant pas je
vous demande les points les plus chauds
est-ce que sur ces points là si vous me
permettez de vous répondre je vous en
prie
on est très exactement dans la limite de
l'exercice je m'explique
on a un enjeu considérable comme aucune
génération avant nous qui est la manière
dont on décarbonate nos modes de
transport notre économie notre façon de
vivre mais face à ça si on embarque pas
les gens et que ce sont systématiquement
les plus excités ou les plus extrémistes
qui se font entendre on va perdre toute
une partie de la population et vous
additionnez un projet de stockage de
déchets un bout de route un projet de
retenue ou de bassine alors que penser
que ces noirs ou que c'est blanc de
manière générale sans regarder la
réalité du sous-sol du terrain du nombre
d'habitants de là où on en est c'est
faire un jure aux réalités locales au
consensus qui se sont fait ou pas à la
réalité de ce que sont les acteurs de
terrain alors ça participe peut-être
d'une forme de grande simplification qui
permet de présenter les choses mais ça
n'est pas conforme à la réalité on
reparlera peut-être de ce qui vous
intéresse sur le fait de ce que je vais
vous dire la manifestation l'opposition
soit les manifestations dès lors
qu'elles ne sont pas infiltrées par des
gens qui ne viennent que pour casser
comme c'était le cas à Sainte Soline
elles ont vocation à pouvoir se on ne
manque pas en France de d'occasions de
manifester ou de possibilités de le
faire et donc quand il y a des
exceptions c'est bien parce qu'il y a
des indices graves et concordants et qui
malheureusement ont été avérés il y a
quelques jours on va parler de l'eau le
l'ONU a récemment évoqué une crise
mondiale imminente de l'eau et vous avez
au côté du président présenté un plan o
avec 53 mesures dedans qui visent à
réduire la consommation à innover
l'objectif principal c'est une baisse de
10% de la consommation d'ici 2030 il y
aura un écowatts de l'eau mais quand on
se rappelle des assises de l'eau il y a
4 ans l'objectif c'était bien 30% d'ici
2030 est-ce que il est moins dix ans
quand même ce plan pourquoi un tel
manque d'ambition pas du tout le plan ou
plus exactement les annonces qui avaient
été faites c'était à l'horizon 2035 et
c'était 25% en 2035
là ce que nous présentons dans le cadre
de ces dans le cadre de ce plan haut
c'est pas juste de présenter un chiffre
ou de le balancer dans la nature c'est
d'expliquer comment on l'atteint
la France elle est divisée en bassin ce
qu'on va faire c'est précisément
territorialiser les objectifs vous avez
des coins de France dans lesquels vous
avez des marges importantes pour
diminuer les prélèvements d'autres qui
vont nécessiter des investissements avec
des typologies qui sont pas les mêmes
dans certains endroits c'est la place
des centrales nucléaires et les besoins
de refroidissement qui compte dans
d'autres c'est les prélèvements qui sont
liés à l'agriculture dans un autre
bassin ou dans un sous-bassin on a
aujourd'hui une difficulté qui sont
d'abord des difficultés d'eau potable et
de rupture d'eau potable pendant l'été
globalement sur les 30 milliards sur les
33 milliards pour être précis de
prélèvement l'enjeu ça va être
d'identifier avant la fin de l'année
dans le cadre de plan d'adaptation
changement climatique les trois
milliards de mètres cubes que nous
allons économiser
30%, on a rien fait depuis les assises
de l'eau pour en arriver à cette
situation
que on soit à 25% dans 12 ans c'est une
perspective qui est tout à fait crédible
le sujet c'est de renseigner d'ici la
fin de l'année la façon dont nous
faisons 10% de baisse tout de suite
c'est la territorialisation de cette
baisse ce que ça veut dire que vous
pouvez vous engager sur 30% en 2035 je
m'engage sur ceux sur quoi nous avons
concerté avec l'ensemble des acteurs je
m'engage à considérer que la question de
l'eau dont on n'a pas parlé pendant des
années ni sur le plan mondial ni
finalement que très peu sur le plan
local elle devienne désormais un point
d'agenda qui va revenir de manière
systématique dès le mois de décembre on
fera le premier évaluation avec le
Comité national de l'eau des décisions
qui ont été prises et de ce qui a été
fait et vous pouvez être certaine que
dans un an dans deux ans dans trois ans
on va reparler de ces mesures le sujet
c'est quoi c'est qu'on a un dérèglement
climatique qui fait qu'on a à la fois
des sols qui sont plus secs des
températures qui sont plus chaudes donc
davantage des vapeaux transpiration une
augmentation des températures qui fait
que malheureusement la part d'eau
disponible ensuite va diminuer de 10 à
40% en fonction des scénarios de
réchauffement et donc il faut qu'on
constituent à vivre avec moi et donc
votre principale mesure c'est quand même
de baisser la consommation de 10%
vous en attendez beaucoup des citoyens
finalement c'est une politique publique
la sobriété c'est pas une impuissance
publique vous savez la sobriété il y a
une époque où on aurait pu appeler ça la
lutte contre gaspillage et à certains
égards non seulement je pense que c'est
une politique publique qui concerne tout
le monde mais que c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit pas perdre de vue parce que
dans beaucoup de cas c'est pas c'est à
cause d'excès dans la manière de faire
parce qu'on s'est habitué à une forme
d'abondance qu'on a perdu une forme de
sagesse je vous donne deux exemples
c'est que c'est une façon de se
défausser quand même sur les individus
et de ne pas prendre ses responsabilités
je peux vous assurer qu'on les prend à
l'inverse est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement que un ministre un président
de la République ou un député il va tout
seul faire 3 milliards de mètres cubes
d'économie ou que tout va se régler avec
des textes contenus de la ventilation de
l'eau et du besoin aujourd'hui d'en
parler
on va en parler les mesures du
gaspillage c'est quoi d'abord on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation où
nous réutilisons pas les eaux usées et
les eaux grises on a mis en place des
textes pour des raisons de santé
publique le principe de précaution et
donc eaux
usées retraitées
1% d'Espagne et effectivement 80% en
Israël l'enjeu très vite c'est de faire
sauter ses verrous qui sont des verrou
réglementaires on est en train de
finaliser les différents éléments c'est
déjà le cas pour une partie de
l'agroalimentaire pour éviter de la
population française alors oui parce que
on n'a pas tenu ce discours sur ce qui
était possible et le deuxième verrou
pour les constructions neuves c'est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui dans le fond de nos
toilettes on a de l'eau potable alors
que dans notre maison on a
potentiellement de l'eau usée depuis
l'agriculture ça pose aucun problème
pour la consommation humaine on les
retraites vous avez aujourd'hui des
études très poussées qui permettent de
montrer que ça ne pose pas de
difficultés on va pas proposer des boire
aujourd'hui ces taux là je pense que ça
n'est pas le sujet du moment on a déjà
tellement d'autres sur lequel on peut
aller avant d'aller sur celui là il y a
déjà des centaines de millions de mètres
cubes à réutiliser puis le deuxième
volet de l'adulte entre le gaspillage
c'est un milliard de mètres cubes un
milliard de mètres cubes c'est le
chiffre de ce que nous perdons tous les
ans dans les fuites des réseaux d'eau
potable et là vous m'interrogez sur ce
que la puissance peut faire elle met de
l'argent mais en contrepartie elle va
exiger de la part des élus qui sont à
plus de 50% de fuite les 170 communes
qui sont repérées pour le moment des
plans pour aller diminuer de manière
drastique ces fuite parce qu'on ne peut
pas continuer à faire autant donner 475
millions d'euros agences de l'eau vous
avez des aides pour les 170 communes
identifiées mais enfin bon pour les
autres comment est-ce qu'elles vont
pouvoir financer alors d'abord le budget
des agences de l'eau passe annuellement
de 2 milliards à 2 milliards 7 donc
c'est pas 475 millions d'euros on fait
plus rien c'est bien une augmentation de
plus de 20% de leurs moyens ensuite dans
le plan il y a des aquaps Près
c'est-à-dire des prêts sur des très
longues durées qui pour les
collectivités locales sont importants
parce qu'une canalisation vous
l'amortissez pas en un ou deux ans mais
sur 30 ça va pas générer une
augmentation des impôts locaux tout ça
pour les collectivités qui se sentent
quand même souvent étranglées
aujourd'hui en France l'eau paylo c'est
pas via la taxe foncière ou les taxes
sur les entreprises que les que les
choses se font c'est au travers du prix
de l'eau là où il y a des fuites
importantes là où il y a eu des
sous-investissement de réseau il y aura
des augmentations de prix alors pour
arrêter ce gaspillage en revanche vous
avez aujourd'hui des quantités de
territoires en France où l'impact des
mesures qu'on a annoncé vont être
extrêmement faibles parce qu'il y a déjà
un réseau qui a un réseau sur le prix de
l'eau là vous prévoyez une tarification
progressive de l'eau alors je comprends
bien pour quelqu'un qui veut remplir sa
piscine ce serait assez normal que il
paye un petit peu plus qu'un autre mais
par exemple quand on a une famille
nombreuse est-ce que c'est normal
finalement qu'on paye beaucoup plus
quand on a plusieurs enfants est-ce
qu'il y aura un tarif familial comment
ça peut se passer il y a plein de
manières de le faire et c'est la raison
pour laquelle ce qu'on souhaite c'est
aussi s'appuyer sur une expertise
intermédiaire du conseiller économique
et social environnemental qui va va être
missionné pour nous faire des
propositions sur la manière de faire le
tarif de l'eau il dépend des élus locaux
et on a deux sujets aux deux extrémités
le tarif social le plus social pour les
gens qui ont peu de moyens aujourd'hui
toutes les collectivités qu'ils soient
déjà la possibilité de le mettre en
place on est au balbutiements ces tarifs
sociaux et le tarif progressif autour de
cette idée qui consiste à se dire que
même une famille nombreuse
l'impact
une personne ça boit 1,5 litres d'eau
par jour donc c'est pas la quantité
d'eau qu'on boit qui a la fin fait la
différence vous avez les douches vous
avez mais même quand vous additionnez
tout ça c'est relativement simple de
faire la différence entre ce qui relève
de la vie normale d'une maison et le
remplissage d'une piscine ou le fait
d'aller arroser de manière régulière sa
pelouse vous avez des seuil en mètre
cube qui sont assez faciles à déterminer
dernière question sur les jets privés et
oui il y a une proposition de loi qui
est défendue par Julien Bayou à cette
semaine est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'interdiction des vols en jet privé en
France non
je ne suis pas favorable à une
proposition qui me semble davantage
relevé 1% de la population mondiale qui
est responsable de 50% des émissions de
l'aviation alors je ne sais pas d'où
vient ce chiffre moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'en France
nous émettons 400 millions de tonnes de
gaz à effet de serre les jet privé c'est
400000 tonnes c'est à dire 0,1% des
émissions nationales et dans ce 01% vous
avez les vols sanitaires vous avez les
vols tous les vols qui d'ailleurs ne
sont même pas dans la profession donc on
parle peut-être de 200000 tonnes je veux
dire qu'elle est mon problème il faut
pas demander quand même un effort alors
on voit ce qui est visé évidemment c'est
les plus riches qui prennent les jets
privés ce qu'il faut pas quand même
demander dans ce contexte là un effort
assez plus riche on se rappelle de
Clément Beaune qui disait que c'est une
sorte de symbole non seulement vous avez
raison sur le fait que c'est légitime
mais je vous signale que pour la
première fois
désormais le prix du kérosène est indexé
sur le prix de l'essence les mêmes
écologistes qui aujourd'hui sont en
train de vouloir faire le buzz ou de
prétendre sous couvert d'écologie
reprendre
le budget qui a voté quantité
quand ils étaient au gouvernement que ne
se sont-ils à ce moment-là
des péchés d'aligner les fiscalités ça
leur est venu quand ils sont arrivés
dans l'opposition
climatique on n'était pas là on en reste
là c'est suffisant mais on en reste pas
du tout là si vous voulez qu'on
poursuivre sur les jets privés je peux
être beaucoup plus précis il y a à la
fois le niveau d'incorporation des des
carburants de synthèse qui est prévu il
y a une augmentation des taxes avec une
échelle européenne jusqu'en 2033 qui
correspond à des accords que nous avons
pris en compte ce qui existe déjà entre
guillemets c'est à dire il y aura pas de
nature
hypocrisie qui consisterait à prendre
une mesure qui s'applique à l'intérieur
du périmètre de la France et permettre
que les aéroports qui seraient en
proximité immédiate puisse contourner
cette obligation ça n'aurait pas de sens
voilà typiquement un sujet sur lequel là
un sujet européen a travaillé merci Tom
merci Brigitte on se tourne tout de
suite vers Vincent roux aux figuerolive
bonsoir mon cher Vincent comment
allez-vous bien vous avez une question
d'actualité monsieur le ministre c'est
par là de l'autre côté voilà une
question d'actualité à soumettre à
Christophe Béchu oui bonsoir Christophe
la question d'actualité bien c'est celle
qui est posée par le Président de la
République ce midi puisqu'il a
enfin il a pris la parole après la
conclusion des travaux de la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie est-ce que
il a il a il a demandé ce que soit mise
en place un projet de loi sur la fin de
vie d'ici la fin de l'été est-ce qu'il
faut que ce projet de loi selon vous
suive les recommandations de la
convention citoyenne ou est-ce qu'il
faut plutôt suivre les recommandations
des soignants notamment qui ont écrit
une tribune dans Le Figaro qui disent
que d'abord et avant tout aujourd'hui il
faut développer les soins palliatifs
alors
le président dans la manière dont il a
conclu les travaux en disant qu'il
souhaitaient une loi d'abord il a
rappelé une évidence c'est qu'on peut
faire des conventions citoyennes mais
qu'à la fin il faut un temps pour que la
démocratie parlementaire s'exprime et
c'est ce temps qui permet de tenir
compte à la fois de ce qui a été
l'expérience et le point d'arrivée le 8
mai de cette convention citoyenne et par
exemple l'expression très légitime des
soignants mais il y a finalement quelque
chose qui semble au moins immergé dans
tout ça c'est ce consensus sur le fait
que la priorité des priorités c'est le
fait de renforcer les soins palliatifs
parce qu'on a au travers de ces
auditions au travers de ces discussions
au travers de la tribune que vous avez
publiée aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il y
a sans doute plus de la moitié des
endroits en France où il devrait y avoir
des soins palliatifs ou il n'existe pas
de manière suffisante ou l'information
des patients ne se fait pas dans de
bonnes conditions donc on voit bien que
sur ce sujet là on peut pas se contenter
d'un oui ou non et d'ailleurs y compris
la manière dont les 184 citoyens
rendu un avis
nuancé ça nécessite maintenant une
traduction législative qui doit être
aussi prudente et aussi respectueuse de
la diversité de leur avis que n'ont été
leur travaux vous retenez davantage la
nécessité de renforcer les soins
palliatifs que le vœu exprimer alors la
consensuel au sein de la convention
d'aller vers le l'aide activa mourir je
retiens le fait que il y a un premier
consensus qui s'est fait autour de ses
soins palliatifs et qui pour le coup
correspond aussi à celui des soignants
français c'est d'aller au-delà je sais
bien mais la manière dont on y va le
fait par exemple d'aller expliquer que
les mineurs ne sont pas concernés le
fait d'aller préciser les conditions
dans lesquelles les choses pourraient se
faire le fait de s'interroger aussi sur
le qui le fait comment est-ce qu'on
s'assure du consentement dans quelles
conditions on voit bien que
il y a le fond du débat qui est
forcément qui nous touche tous parce
qu'on sait que c'est une étape qui nous
attendra dans la vie à la différence de
dos des débats sociétaux dont on peut se
sentir plus éloigné parce que ça
correspond à des moments qui sont déjà
passés dans nos vies d'hommes et de
femmes mais il y a une deuxième
dimension c'est la façon dont ça peut
aussi exprimer une forme de mal-être de
désespérance ou de solitude d'une partie
de nos aînés parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont mêlées et je pense qu'on
est malheureusement dans des temps où on
a atteint des records de solitude on n'a
jamais été aussi nombreux on n'a jamais
été aussi connecté mais les occasions
finalement de discuter avec une vraie
personne dans une vraie journée elle
participe aussi une forme de mal-être
merci beaucoup Vincent à tout à l'heure
bonsoir arrive très à soyez le bienvenu
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro c'est à VOUS bonsoir Monsieur
Béchu alors il y a eu une élection
législative partielle dans l'Ariège ce
week-end deuxième tour une candidat qui
n'était pas soutenue par le Parti
socialiste mais qui se réclame de la
gauche a gagné contre une soutenu par le
Parti socialiste et la nupesse
c'est
étrange comme victoire parce que c'était
pas attendu est-ce que puisque vous avez
besoin d'élargir votre majorité au
gouvernement vous demandez à cette
à cette nouvelle députée madame projet
de siéger et bien dans les rangs de
l'horizon de renaissance ou du MoDem de
la majorité présidentielle puisque le
Parti socialiste n'en veut pas dans ces
rangs bonsoir Monsieur trear alors on
est effectivement dans cette situation
baroque que vous décrivez mais
si je devais ce soir être l'auteur d'une
invitation pour lui expliquer qu'elle
est la bienvenue dans la majorité
présidentielle ça épargnerait à la
gauche de se poser vraiment la question
de ce qui s'est passé dimanche et c'est
d'ailleurs toute une partie de la thèse
des leaders de LFI et de dire c'était
pas vraiment une candidate socialiste et
finalement elle est macroniste
puisqu'elle a eu d'autres voies non vous
avez bien raison de dire qu'il y a deux
candidates de gauche qui se sont
affrontés et celles qui étaient hostile
à la ligne de la nupes et au fait en
gros d'être mis sous l'emprise de LFI là
emporté de manière très large avec votre
soutien mais pas seulement avec le nôtre
avec le soutien de beaucoup de parties
qui considèrent aujourd'hui que LFI joue
un jeu dangereux qui consiste à
hystériser des débats et que pour toute
une partie de la sociale démocratie
c'est une impasse c'est ce que dit
Monsieur Cazeneuve
et nous tendons la main à toutes celles
et tous ceux qui veulent travailler
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
accepteriez que Monsieur Cazeneuve
monsieur Valls et bien rejoignent la
majorité présidentielle et occupe des
fonctions à l'intérieur de cette
majorité moi je ne me lèverai pas
de droite est-ce que vous estimez que
l'avenir il passe aussi par un
recentrage pardon de cette ce n'est
cette figure de style ce néologisme qui
consiste à aller voir un peu ce qui se
passe à gauche puisque bien vous vous
êtes un peu éloigné de cette gauche la
majorité présidentielle
ces dernières semaines ou ces derniers
mois il y a des textes qui parfois ont
reçu le soutien de l'élu de gauche je
pense par exemple au texte sur les
énergies renouvelables je pense à
l'inverse on fait qu'on a pu trouver une
majorité sur le nucléaire parfois de
dire que sur les 23 textes qui ont été
présentés par le gouvernement
d'Elizabeth borne il y en a 20 qui ont
été adoptés 149-3 et avec des logiques
de dépassement texte par texte bien sûr
l'intensité du débat sur les retraites
ça place au niveau médiatique et
le caractère très naturel de la fois la
contestation parce que c'est une figure
classique sur les retraites mais aussi
de l'intensité des débats qu'on a sur
ces sujets qu'on a l'impression que tout
se résume à ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers mois ça n'a pas été le cas
auparavant il y a pas de raison que ça
le soit après et donc je continue
plaider moi pour que les hommes et les
femmes de bonne volonté quel que soit
leurs obédiences et les endroits d'où
ils viennent puissent faire en sorte non
pas de vous donner un coup de main au
gouvernement mais au pays c'est quand
même assez paradoxal qu'une partie de
ces familles réclame la proportionnelle
et que placer dans une situation où il y
a une majorité relative tout le monde
explique que c'est à ceux qu'on a
majorité relative de travailler seul
Monsieur Actuellement alors que on est
quand même dans une crise sociale très
importante qui est lié à la réforme des
retraites est-ce que vous estimez que
l'adversaire le plus redoutable
aujourd'hui c'est celui qui soutient les
grévistes les manifestants dans la rue
c'est à dire la gauche la nupesse ou
est-ce que c'est le rassemblement
national qui est mythique depuis le
début de cette réforme
d'abord je pense que soutenir les
grévistes et les manifestants
c'est logique et légitime jamais nous
n'avons remué
le sujet c'est la manière dont on le
fait c'est les arguments qu'on utilise
et c'est quand on franchit un certain
nombre de lignes qui consiste à
s'attaquer ou à la dignité des personnes
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui fait un
continuum entre l'attitude des élus de
la France insoumise et ce qui se passe
je pense que les manifestations je pense
qu'on est dans un jeu dangereux ou
certains font le pari du désordre et ils
le font de manière consciente et
volontaire les amis de Monsieur
Mélenchon alors même que le désordre il
appelle de manière logique comme un
retour de balancier à une volonté
d'ordre et que cette volonté d'ordre
elle sera demain incarnée par Marine Le
Pen si on reste dans cette espèce de jeu
dangereux les extrêmes finissent par se
rejoindre on l'a vu d'ailleurs de
manière spectaculaire sur certaines
circonscriptions vous aviez des votes
Mélenchon qui ont pu devenir des votes
Marine Le Pen dans des proportions
extrêmement élevées avec des colères qui
se rassemblent et qui se répondent et
donc oui il y a effectivement un risque
qu'en prophétisant le désordre on
finisse par se retrouver à faire arriver
l'extrême droite
vous tentez beaucoup contre l'extrême
gauche et on vous entend très peu contre
l'extrême droite je vous invite demain
soir sur LCP à jeter un coup d'œil au
débat qui sera
organisément par le rassemblement
national pour parler d'écologie
d'inflation et de pouvoir d'achat et
pour lesquels j'aurai l'occasion aux
banc de répondre pour le compte
gouvernement c'est un peu une esquive
votre réponse parce que la réalité c'est
que dans une émission qui est sympa
au contraire vous auriez pu accueillir
avec élégance le fait que
en gros monsieur Mélenchon fait le jeu
Madame Le Pen c'est ce que vous dites
très exactement très bien
dans un peu moins de quatre ans
maintenant le l'élection présidentielle
aura lieu en 2027 tout le monde en dépit
de ce qu'on peut dire à les yeux rivés
sur cette date puisque le président de
la République ne pourra pas se
représenter et tout le monde a des yeux
rivés vers votre
favori qui s'appelle Edouard Philippe et
qui est à la tête enfin qui qui est un
parti qui s'appelle horizon auquel vous
appartenez
Édouard Philippe que doit-il faire
pour entretenir le désir
d'ici à trois ans et demi
il a fondé un parti politique qui a
amené un flotteur droit à l'intérieur de
la majorité avec un groupe parlementaire
à l'Assemblée avec des élections
sénatoriales dans quelques mois qui
seront une
occasion de renforcer l'ancrage
d'horizon dans le pays et je pense qu'il
a un rôle utile et que quand il explique
qu'il est loyal mais libre il est utile
dans la loyauté pour aller rappeler la
manière qui soutien gouvernement et
c'est utile qui est à l'intérieur de la
majorité des gens qui en étant pas en
responsabilité du quotidien pense
l'avenir se préoccupe de sujets qu'il
faudra qu'on mette à l'agenda plus tard
je pense qu'ensuite le meilleur moyen de
se préparer c'est surtout de pas être
obsédé par cette élection présidentielle
parce que 2027 même si nous y pensons et
nous le regardons c'est une éternité ce
quinquennat n'a même pas un an on est
dans un temps où aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui se va se passer dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent
certainement pas ceux qui auraient déjà
une forme d'obsession personnelle ou
même collective pour ce qui se vivra
dans quatre ans ça n'est pas le sujet du
moment et ça ce serait profondément
contre-produ je sais que ça n'est pas
son cas est-ce que
les problèmes de santé qui dont ils
souffrent aujourd'hui sont d'après vous
un handicap pour cette élection pour
pour son avenir politique
alors qu'il s'est expliqué dessus c'est
pour ça que je pose la question je
l'entends j'ai été très frappé par
certains détournements sur les réseaux
sociaux qui montrent qu'il y a parfois
une frontière qui s'estompe sur ces
sujets de dignité ce que je crois c'est
qu'il a fait avec beaucoup de
transparence
beaucoup de courage et surtout beaucoup
de sincérité ensuite
je pense que les Français que l'élection
présidentielle ça n'est pas un concours
dans lequel on prend un aspect on dit
sec et un communiqué de ceci ou de cela
on regarde une personne dans son enterre
on regarde le programme qui propose au
pays on regarde le chemin qu'il a
parcouru et celui qui propose qu'on
parcourt ensemble et que c'est pas
là-dessus que se joue une élection merci
petite dernière question si vous me le
permettez
accord d'une interview un magazine qui
s'appelle Playboy qui est un magazine
ine de charme est-ce que vous estimez
que c'est la place d'un ministre que de
s'exprimer dans un journal de ce type je
vais
très cache avec vous j'ai vraiment cru
dans un premier temps c'était
l'information
de ce week-end bon ça n'est pas le cas
ça n'est pas du tout le genre
d'expression à titre personnel que je
ferai
[Musique]
je ne suis pas abonné je ne compte pas
le devenir à un magazine de ce type
je partage l'expression que ça pourrait
être approprié au moins contenu du
contexte et du moment ensuite
c'est sa liberté et c'est la manière
dont te l'exprime et de ce point de vue
elle a l'habitude de casser les codes
pour faire passer des messages et que
vous n'approuvez pas nécessairement
c'est ce que je viens d'entretenir mon
genre de communication merci merci
beaucoup Yves dans un instant mais la
niveau gel va nous rejoindre c'est
natrice Europe Écologie Les Verts il y a
une consultation ce week-end plus
précisément dimanche à Paris pour ou
contre les trottinettes en libre-service
Angers il y a des trottinettes oui en
libre-service oui
que pensez-vous d'abord de la
consultation et ensuite de la façon dont
la mère de Paris essaye de réglementer
de régler ce problème puisque c'en est
devenu un à Paris alors plusieurs choses
d'abord incontestablement
les trottinettes ont changé une partie
de nos paysages urbains dans les grandes
villes
notamment parce que beaucoup d'usagers
les utilisent sur les trottoirs
en même temps ces trottinettes elles
permettent de se passer de véhicules
carbonés elles offrent une forme de
liberté en particulier pour des
étudiants je le vois dans ma ville où
c'est un mode qui est plébiscité en
particulier par des jeunes je pense que
l'interdiction n'est pas la solution
interdiction c'est la solution de
faciliter et que le besoin de liberté ce
que ça offre en terme de de possibilités
de se déplacer il faut au contraire
l'encadrer comme on commence à le faire
parce qu'encore une fois à l'échelle de
ce mode de déplacement c'est très récent
les premières règles concernant les
trottinettes elle date de la l'homme qui
est en vigueur globalement depuis le
début de l'année 2020 je trouve que de
prononcer une interdiction si peu de
temps après sur la base de la
consultation c'est la raison parce que
c'était le vote contre vous regrettez ça
pour la ville de capital je dis pas ça
je suis surpris que qu'on aille proposer
une mesure d'interdiction à quelque
chose qui me semble appartenir au panel
des options de mobilité dont on a besoin
pour diminuer la place de la voiture
Mélanie Vogel bonsoir à vous bienvenue
merci d'avoir vous aussi accepté le
principe de ce débat avec Christophe
Béchu je rappelle que vous êtes
sénatrice Europe Écologie Les Verts vous
voulez revenir peut-être sur Sainte
Soline les méga bassines surtout oui
d'abord bonjour bonsoir Monsieur le
Ministre bonsoir
alors bon je reviendrai pas sur ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure sur la question
du maintien de l'ordre il y aurait
beaucoup à dire mais sur le fond de
cette affaire de megavassine j'aimerais
que vous nous expliquer pourquoi au fond
sur le projet lui-même vous continuez à
soutenir un projet j'aimerais quand même
rappeler ce que c'est les méga bassines
parce qu'en dehors des images de
violence qu'on a pu voir il y a quand
même un projet qui consiste à dans une
situation où à cause du réchauffement
climatique à cause de la crise
climatique on a des épisodes de
sécheresse de plus en plus fort et donc
des nappes phréatiques qui y compris en
hiver c'était le cas cette année ce vide
le projet des méga bassines consiste à
aller prendre de l'eau dans des nappes
phréatiques qui se vide et donc on sait
qu'il y a beaucoup d'années on ne pourra
même pas aller prendre de l'eau parce
qu'il y en a plus et cette eau pour
aller nourrir des cultures qui sont
surconsommatrices d'eau puisqu'on
consomme de l'eau pour aller cultiver
par exemple dans le marais poitevin du
maïs qui n'est pas adapté au Marais
Poitevin pour l'exporter ou le donner à
manger au bétail donc comment expliquer
sur le fond du projet que vous continuez
à soutenir un projet qui consiste au
fond à aggraver le problème de la
ressource en eau en France très bien
j'ai posé
la meilleure retenue la meilleure
bassine c'est la nappe phréatique très
bien elle évite les vapeaux
transpiration elle permet au contraire
de faire en sorte de pouvoir stocker de
l'eau dans de bonnes conditions et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle un
des combats principaux sur lequel j'ai
été heureux d'avoir un peu de soutien de
la part des écologistes au Sénat c'est
de pas trop dénaturer de la loi qui
consiste à lutter contre l'étalement
urbain au titre du 0 artificialisation
nette quand on a posé ça notre pays les
divers la réalité des sols des sous-sols
elle doit tenir compte de ce que nous
savons la particularité des Deux-Sèvres
et de l'endroit où on se situe c'est
qu'on est sur des sous-sols qui sont
karstiques c'est à dire avec des nappes
qui sont des nappes fuyantes et donc là
où normalement les nappes conservent
cette eau toute l'année là c'est nappe
elle fuit quoi qu'il arrive avec une eau
qui cesse d'être disponible pendant une
partie de l'été et donc s'il y a bien un
endroit où il peut y avoir un intérêt à
avoir un dispositif qui consiste à
prendre cette eau pour faire en sorte
qu'elle puisse être disponible l'été
plutôt que de puiser dans les rivières
c'est là c'est d'ailleurs ce que disent
les nappes qui fument on en a besoin
juste c'est dire ce que disent les
études les conseils scientifiques ont
été mobilisés le BRGM dans la note qu'il
a pu rendre c'est pas le ministre actuel
de la transition écologique qui a validé
ce projet c'est un large consensus avec
la région socialiste le département
républicain
450 agriculteurs réunis dans une
coopérative de l'eau avec y compris une
députée de la nupestre qui a signé le
protocole qui s’est engagé dans un
process qui consiste à dire on aura des
bassines en contrepartie on va changer
nos pratiques pour diminuer nos besoins
en termes de prélèvement donc pour
diminuer pour qu'on ait plus besoin de
bassine vous nous dit qu'on construit
des bassines pour ne plus avoir besoin
de bassines non on assure une forme de
transition qui quand vous lisez
notamment les études vous explique que
ça va permettre d'éviter de se retrouver
avec des aseques pendant l'été en allant
puiser de l'eau au moment où la
biodiversité ou les poissons ont besoin
et où les captages d'eau potable en ont
besoin alors ce qui m'amène à ma
deuxième question
plus largement sur la question de l'eau
puisque on voit bien le problème c'est
que dans un territoire où effectivement
les nappes fuit mais ça a un sens à une
utilité cette eau elle est pas perdue
elle va ailleurs elle va irriguer les
sous-sols et vous savez que les végétaux
principalement se nourrissent de l'eau
qui a dans le sol pas de l'eau qui
arrive voilà et pour revenir à la
question donc plus largement de la
gestion de l'eau sur le plan O
alors bon il y a plein de mesures très
bien j'ai rien contre aucune des mesures
en particulier mais il y a quand même
quelque chose d'énorme qui manque de mon
point de vue et j'aimerais vous demander
pourquoi on a plus de la moitié de l'eau
qui consommait en France qui consommait
par Agriculture et vous savez que on a
entre 90 et 95% des surfaces agricoles
qui ne sont pas irriguées
de la pluie elle vient du sol
si on veut réellement
diminuer nos besoins en eau il y a une
chose à faire avant le
l'aquapré l'Echo what de l'eau etc c'est
de faire de planifier la transition de
notre modèle agricole vers un modèle qui
soit moins demandeur en eau c'est à dire
Varent modèle qui soit agroécologique et
qui permettent qu'on cultive des
végétaux adaptés
en plus je vais vous dire j'ai
répondez-moi je pense pas qu'on soit en
désaccord et tout l'enjeu c'est le mot
transition et
pour être très clair cette eau dans
l'agriculture a besoin c'est au
consommer par l'agriculture et c'est
pour nous nourrir on n'est pas sur une
eau qui servirait à les remplir les
piscines ou les jacuzzi des agriculteurs
on est sur une autre dont on a besoin
pour se nourrir et cette eau-là c'est
pas pour nous nourrir c'est pour
exporter et nourrir du bétail vous ne
pouvez pas résumer
450 agriculteurs qui sont en polyculture
élevage à un type de production ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité locale donc
même quand je dézoome là où je vous
rejoins c'est que on voit bien le
changement du climat la nature des sols
fait que on a aujourd'hui des cultures
qui sont en Méditerranée qui vont
remonter on a des typologies de culture
qui sont sans doute plus adaptées au
climat vers lesquels nous allons aller
mais on peut pas changer ça sur un
claquement de doigts l'enjeu c'est la
planification c'est le fait précisément
d'être capable de regarder comment
l'accompagne et vous avez dans les
mesures du soutien par exemple à des
projets d'IR le mot sobriété il s'impose
aussi pour l'agriculture avec une
sobriété à l'hectare vers laquelle il
faut aller vous avez raison on a que 7%
aujourd'hui des de la surface agricole
utile qui bénéficie de cette irrigation
ça fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
on va bouger qui sont à la fois dans le
plan et dans la planification écologique
au sens plus large sur la décarbonation
de notre modèle sur lequel on travaille
pour le mois de juin alors est-ce qu'on
passe au deuxième sujet qui est la
politique ferroviaire oui
autre sujet la politique ferroviaire
d'un joli poser une question parce que
donc il y a le plan de train globalement
pareil je veux dire moi toutes les
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens j'ai
pas de problème mais on a en France je
crois un des obstacles majeurs à
l'utilisation du train et des transports
en commun en général c'est la question
du prix
le train c'est trop cher c'est une des
raisons principales pour lesquelles les
gens ne prennent pas le train surtout
quand on est en famille ou quand on est
quatre ou cinq allez faire l'île
Marseille en train c'est hors de prix
les écologistes malheureusement sont pas
encore au pouvoir en France mais ils
sont au pouvoir dans un certain nombre
de gouvernements européens dans 6
gouvernements européens et les
transports font partie des priorités des
écologistes quand ils arrivent au
pouvoir et il y a deux pays par exemple
qui sont de très bons exemples d'une
politique qui est typiquement écologiste
c'est-à-dire que avec une mesure on
arrive à régler à la fois la question
climatique la question sociale et aussi
la question géopolitique puisque en
étant moins dépendant du gaz et du
pétrole on est moins dépendants de la
Russie et on améliore la paix dans le
monde c'est par exemple l'introduction
de ce qui a été fait en Allemagne du
ticket climat ou en Autriche qui est
même un ticket qui donne accès à tous
les trains et tous les transports en
commun et qui marche voilà c'est très
simple c'est une mesure écologique ça
fonctionne est-ce que le gouvernement
est prêt à travailler à la mise en place
d'un ticket climat sur le modèle
définissez quand même le principe alors
en Autriche par exemple c'est un
abonnement ça coûte 3 euros par jour
donc ça fait un peu plus de 1000 euros
par an avec ça vous avez accès de façon
illimitée à tous les trains à tous les
transports en commun d'accord
fait une expérimentation à 9 euros par
mois puis l'ont mis en place de façon
permanente à 49 euros par mois ça a
permis ça permet en Allemagne d'éviter
600 000 tonnes de CO2 par mois et
surtout ça change les pratiques ça amène
de nouveau alors est-ce que ça vous
intéresse d'abord ce qui m'intéresse
c'est d'entendre Mélanie Vogel vanter
des pays où les écologistes acceptent de
travailler avec la droite
parce que dans les deux cas pas dans les
deux cas en Autriche il vous a quand
même pas échappé que
un système différent en France que
partout ailleurs en Europe donc moi j'ai
pas de problème avec ça vous savez je
viens du Parlement européen voilà
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant le
problème c'est que souvent ici dans le
débat qu'on a en France vous allez
suggérer qu'on aille prendre des mesures
sans accepter de venir donner un coup de
main de manière gouvernementale dans ces
pays c'est dans les contrats de
coalition ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est dans les contrats de coalition que
il y a eu des accords entre les
écologistes et la droite que ce soit en
Autriche ou en Allemagne ensuite est-ce
qu'elle a proportionnelle un système
parlementaire ce que j'ai toujours
défendu est-ce que les écologistes
défendent y compris pour la France mais
donc l'idée que si on n'est pas de
gauche on a pas le droit d'être
écologiste et évidemment ça pousse une
difficulté parce que ça veut dire qu'à
la fin c'est libéral c'est compliqué de
respecter les limites planétaire c'est
ça le problème je moi j'entends théorie
vous voyez ce qui se passe en Autriche
le cadre de l'Allemagne est intéressant
parce que alors ils ont fait une
politique très très forte mais qui s'est
limitée à l'été avec ces 9 euros ils
sont aujourd'hui sur la recherche du bon
équilibre et du bon modèle sur un
dispositif mensuel illimité
en place c'est 49 € par mois sur les 9 €
et on est sur un dispositif qui même
maintenant est encore transitoire le
fait de vérifier que à la fin il trouve
son équilibre on est en plein réflexion
notre sushi notre souci aujourd'hui il
est le suivant c'est que notre priorité
des priorités c'est d'abord le soutien
la régénération du réseau on a laissé
globalement depuis les années 80 en
faisant le choix des LGV plutôt que le
choix d'un entretien de régénération
tout gouvernement confondu notre réseau
diminué et avant d'être capable aussi
d'ajuster une politique tarifaire il
faut des freins qui roulent il faut de
la fiabilité parce que sinon ça entraîne
une des perdition en parallèle la SNCF
en Allemagne multipliées les les gammes
tarifaires pour justement à côté des
plaintes à Rives faire en sorte que des
gens qui voyagent à plusieurs que des
familles puissent bénéficier de tarifs
qui sont adaptés et moi je crois au fait
qu'il faut
évidemment multiplier les occasions
d'aller susciter l'envie de prendre le
train de rendre le train de plus
attractif la question des tarifs elle se
pose est-ce que normalement est-ce que
vous trouvez que c'est trop cher pour la
plupart des Français la plupart des
déplacements aujourd'hui sont chers et
le train plein tarif c'est cher c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle vous avez
des quantités de dispositif qui
permettent de diminuer cette technique
je reviens au sujet la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on fasse les
efforts manquants dans les
infrastructures qui nous permettront
d'avoir des ambitions les deux sont liés
mais la dernière question pour connaître
bien l'Allemagne en particulier son
réseau ferroviaire je peux vous dire que
les trains il roulent pas mal mieux en
France qu'en Allemagne c'est pas moi
j'ai pas de problème c'est vrai il faut
investir dans le réseau c'est mais
c'était pas ma question ma question
c'est est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui ou
non à travailler il y a plusieurs
modèles le modèle autrichien c'est pas
le même que le modèle allemand c'est
même que le modèle luxembourgeois c'est
pas même comme modèle espagnol mais il y
a une politique tarifaire pour faire que
le train soit accessible et qui a changé
à la fois l'impact climat mais les
comportements donc Madame est-ce que
vous travaillez sur un projet similaire
pour vous répondre de manière claire
Clémentine le ministre délégué chargé
des transports au sein du pôle ministère
a dit que la volonté de travailler sur
un billet unique ou sur un tarif unique
était à l'agenda donc je peux pas mieux
vous dire ce que je souhaite c'est que
sur ce sujet on puisse partager aussi
les contraintes pas seulement les bonnes
idées mais regardez concrètement comment
on y va ça veut dire renoncer à quoi ça
veut dire mettre l'accent sur quoi
comment est-ce que on arrive à un
équilibre global mais le fait
d'encourager nos concitoyens à prendre
le train c'est souhaitable le train
c'est 0,3% seulement de nos émissions
alors que ça représente 10% de nos
déplacements donc ces vertueux à tout
point de vue merci infiniment Mélanie
juste une petite question d'ailleurs de
déplacement avant de rejoindre dans son
roux il y a votre collègue Agnès panière
une hachée qui propose de réduire la
vitesse à 110 km/h vous allez me dire je
suis pas ministre des Transports mais
c'est quand même pour évidemment faire
en sorte qu'il y ait moins d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre est-ce que c'est
une bonne idée elle dit je propose aux
entreprises de passer par le dialogue
social pour inciter pour négocier cette
voilà cette conduite limitée à 110 km/h
vous êtes à ce point traumatisé par par
les 80 km/h d'Édouard Philippe pour pour
faire ce type de proposition que vous
pourriez imposer mais c'est quand même
une drôle d'idée de vouloir à tout prix
chercher des choses qu'on pourrait
imposer qu'est-ce qui empêche un
français vous moi qui que ce soit de
rouler demain à 110 km/h s'il le
souhaite
c'est à dire que on voudrait empêcher
les autres de rouler à cette vitesse et
vous citez cet exemple qu'on encourage
les entreprises que l'État montre
l'exemple puisque c'est plus de 20% de
diminution non seulement je pense qu'on
est dans notre rôle mais c'est ce que
nous faisons on a parlé de l'Allemagne
ce week-end le chancelier allemand a
officialisé le fait que il n'y aurait
pas de baisse des vitesses autorisées
malgré le fait que les vers soi au
gouvernement en Allemagne en considérant
que la transition écologique elle devait
aussi être acceptable socialement
Vincent roux il vous reste par très peu
de temps c'est à vous
oui Christophe de la cohésion des
territoires que vous êtes on observe un
nombre record de démission d'élus
parmi les griefs qui sont
posés par ces beaucoup d'élus il y a les
blocages de centaines de projets de
réalité de réutilisation d'eau usées que
eux ils proposent et qui sont bloqués
par millefeuille administratifs
à avoir pour simplifier les choses et
permettre à ces élus de ne pas
décourager et d'avoir un argument de
plus en argument
bref la réponse brève elle est simple
c'est 1000 projets de réutilisation usés
que nous allons autoriser débrider dans
les jours qui viennent et ce chiffre
c'est un premier chiffre s'il faut aller
au-delà on ira en revanche et le Figaro
on a fait état aujourd'hui
on est après de 1000 démissions de merde
depuis le début du mandat je pense qu'il
faut vraiment être conscient de la
difficulté de la tâche en particulier
dans le cadre d'un mandat qui a commencé
avec le covid dans mon département le
Maine-et-Loire j'ai vu comment le fait
d'avoir des équipes qui se réunissaient
uniquement par visio ça n'a pas permis
au début du mandat de faire en sorte que
la pâte humaine que la convivialité que
la cohésion dont on a besoin pour
ensuite au quotidien j'ai une ville
prenne et ça conduit dans un certain
nombre de cas des éclatements d'équipe
ou à des démissions d'élus je pense que
pour beaucoup le fait aussi d'être resté
chez eux tous les soirs en n'ayant pas
une inauguration et des trucs tout le
temps ça leur a permis de mesurer que il
y avait peut-être aussi un temps pour
pour soi et il faut en avoir conscient
et être à leur côté merci beaucoup
Vincent roux Mélanie Vogel et Christophe
BECHU d'avoir
été l'invité pendant une heure de cette
émission édition publique merci encore
beaucoup à vous on se retrouve pour la
semaine prochaine c'est lundi de Pâques
très bonne semaine sur la chaîne
parlementaire
LCP et Public Sénat bonsoir
[Musique]